let's get into this first story we got
from cnn i love using cnn as a source
when we have horrifying stories because
now it has to be true right
germany locks down unvaccinated people
as leaders plan to make shots compulsory
cnn says unvaccinated people will be
banned from accessing all but the most
essential businesses such as
supermarkets and pharmacies to curb the
spread of the chronovirus outgoing
chancellor angela merkel and her
successor olaf schultz announced
thursday following crisis talks with
regional leaders those who have recently
recovered from covet 19 are not covered
by the ban the pair also backed
proposals for mandatory vaccinations
which if voted through the parliament
could take effect from february at the
earliest
oh okay this is happening it has been
two years
and they're still saying don't worry if
we do this it'll stop the spread of
covid
it's people have said covet is endemic
it's a part of our lives now it'll be
seasonal like the flu let me just add to
that the authoritarianism is now endemic
as well countries will keep implementing
completely bs policies they'll keep
expanding the mandates and my
understanding and i believe this might
be in here what i was reading is that
they said vaccines will be mandatory and
they will expire every nine months let
me see if i can uh
find that
um in here it was in a different here we
go here we go she had that vaccinated
people will lose their vaccination
status nine months after getting their
last shot
apparently in an effort to encourage
booster uptake what that means is
there is no limit to the amount of shots
you have to get they are saying once
every nine months you must get a shot
welcome to the new world order excuse me
the new normal and what was einstein's
definition of insanity because it seems
like we're living it every single day
this is just crazy there's these video
footages there's these photos coming out
of people being segregated in a
supermarket from being vaxxed and
unvaxed there's police officers walking
around rudely interrupting people's
private dinners rudely interrupting
people's haircuts being like give me
your gosh darn paperwork right now i've
been making my own german translations
of them on my own youtube channel but
that's a separate topic but it's
absolutely ridiculous to have a concept
and idea where the state
needs to have you have your paperwork
everywhere you go not just your
identification your medical records and
to have permission from the state to
live your life like a normal person who
gave them this power i didn't john
something tells me that um you're
interested in freedom you know the
foundation for economic education right
is that it yeah no we are uh and if you
look like here's the thing i'd oppose
these even if they worked um but they
don't work anybody who's clinging to the
idea that the vaccines are stopping or
even reducing transmission i don't think
they're looking at the data clearly if
you look anybody know the highest
vaccinated state in the us
uh vermont very much oh and if you look
at if you look at vermont's cases right
now they have more cases right now than
they did last year um they they try to
be careful with correlation though well
for sure but i mean you you can't look
at that anybody that looks at the
numbers and and says we have
vaccination rate 85 percent but our
cases are through the roof like it's not
stopping more data
i hear you one more data point you need
though
are they breakthrough cases well how do
you mean define breakthrough are the
people who are getting covet vaccinated
yes i mean they have to yeah that's not
necessarily
so there could be you know the
vaccination rate
the breakthrough rate is much much
exponentially higher than we were told
at the beginning you know i wrote an
article about this back in august before
anybody before people were really
talking about the breakthrough rate um
at the time you you the
media was reporting something 0.3
maybe a half percent you know maybe at
one percent well we know it's much much
higher than that um we have gobs of data
that supports that as people you know
well so so i think there's actually a
simple
we if we step back
when germany says you have to get
vaccinate every nine months i think what
the issue is
it may be the most vaccinated state the
vaccines may reduce transmission but
they wear off after a certain amount of
time you're still legally vaccinated but
the efficacy has dropped to the point
where you may as well not be yeah
according to the associated press
germany's vaccinated population is 68.7
percent which is the majority of its
population they have seen a surge in
cases and i think they're going to do
what austria did austria also highly
vaccinated country uh
experiencing a lot of new cases and
originally they locked down only the
unvaccinated and then a couple days
later they locked everyone down because
they were using it as an emotional ploy
they knew what they were doing in my
opinion from my perspective and they
were just using this larger kind of
extortion effort in order to try to get
people to take this procedure whether
you want to take this procedure or not
that's your decision we're not giving
you any medical advice we're not telling
you what to do here's the important
thing i think uh it was obvious from the
get-go when they were like in new york
just get one shot and then everything
will go back to normal and then they're
like okay well now it's two and now
you've got the daily beast coming up
being like we screwed up it's not a
booster three shots is the vaccine i
think it's fairly obvious that you give
them an inch they're gonna keep pushing
on it i also think when it comes to the
vaccine i think it probably does what
they say it does they're literally
telling us it stops working like the
efficacy declines so i don't think we
need to look too deep i mean it's just
my opinion ultimately it comes down to
you know don't come to me for medical
advice
i just want to be clear i'm not a
anti-vex i encourage several family
members take the vaccine you're in a
risk group where i think it makes sense
you're going to need a booster my my
wife took the back seat and i said i
think it makes sense um in and i had
covid in march it was a very very
unpleasant experience i was probably the
sickest i've been for for that length of
time um so
covid's real it's it's it's it's deadly
all these problems i'm just i'm just but
i want to be clear i think the idea that
the vaccine everybody admits it doesn't
stop transmission we have very good data
that it doesn't reduce it now like
there's other data that conflicts with
that but but we we published uh coverage
of a report the european journal of
epidemiology i believe it was they they
looked at 67 countries
um
and in thousands of
of counties um
across the world and they said there's
very little correlation there and to the
extent that there is
uh vaccinated
areas had slightly higher cases now this
is transmission the vaccines work
at reducing your risk of being
hospitalized or dying i think i think we
have tons of evidence to support that of
covid
if you take this your chances of dying
or being hospitalized with covet they
fall you know dramatically but the idea
that they they stop transmission is is
not true in the idea that they reduced
it i think you know i think there's
there's we have sound data that says
maybe they don't reduce transmission
it's tough i i will say funny funny
enough one of youtube's rules is that if
you claim the vaccine is is a guaranteed
way to prevent covet it's actually
bannable and they say if it's if you
claim it's a guaranteed way to stop
transmission it's bannable yeah i do
think i do think so that the the vaccine
we're dealing with mrna vaccines not
like the was it attenuated virus is that
is that what's called the the other ones
we do have is novavax the an attenuated
one like they're they're doing a new i
don't know i don't know they're doing
like another one that's like more of a
traditional kind of vaccine because they
needed like the genome or something
i think i think it's fairly
straightforward i think it's a political
issue i think the vaccine probably does
what they say it does and when they come
out and say you know what you actually
need a booster uh you probably need
another a fourth shot i'm like okay
that's not tenable yeah policy wise i'm
like by all means come out and and give
me your advice you know and and report
what the reports are saying and i think
yeah okay maybe it makes sense that in
the first four to six months it'll
reduce transmission or reduce severity
but what happens is you end up with
people who all got vaccinated in march
it's december and now we're like look
the cases are through the roof i'm like
yeah well they got vaccinated eight
months ago and people aren't getting
their booster shots it is not feasible
economically and politically to mandate
nine boosters at every nine months
people aren't going to do it bill maher
said he's not going to do it and so the
way i look at it is it's not so much the
vaccines i think it's the vaccine
mandates are just completely nonsensical
i i would disagree with you a little bit
because i don't think we know yet the
data's still not in and i think we
should say that we don't know but there
you know correlation does not prove
causation and that's an important
distinction here but when we look at the
omnicron variant the first case was
detected in san francisco from a fully
vaccinated person the second case was
detected in minnesota from a triple vac
person who just had his booster shot in
november the third case was also from a
double vaxxed person uh in colorado and
again caught you know correlation does
not prove causation but when we look at
the united kingdom singapore
ireland israel gibraltar a lot of places
that had some of the highest vaccine
rates are dealing with some of the
highest case numbers again we don't know
what that means that's just the data
there's a number of circumstances
involved here but that data should be at
least debated and talked about i think
it's important too like we are talking
cases right now um
we've been focusing on cases for a long
time i think you know if we look even
whether we're cases are rampant um covet
deaths are not you know like the
vaccines are having some success there
um you know but the omicron
everything i've read so far says it
might be more mild and so like are we
concerned that we that the cases are you
know it might be very transmissible like
all those are problems um but
again when we see nations going into
full blown knockdowns and things it's
another overreaction um and when you're
talking about using state force to
compel people to you know get vaccinated
or you can't go to a store um or go out
in public um like it's very dangerous
and we need to you know i get it talking
about this stuff is uncomfortable
talking about vaccines you're always
worried you know like even a mixed
company right you it's always you're
kind of you know pussyfooting around a
little bit trying to you don't want to
offend people but we need to be honest
like using using the state to force
people in this way is is very very
frightening very dangerous that's that's
that's
the issue for me as i say you know i'm
not a scientist i'm a doctor and it's
the issue i have with it is it's so easy
to be wrong
and you end up in a place where you're
like i read this report that says this
and then what do you do when you're
actually sitting in front of someone who
is a doctor who is a scientist and
they're like dude you have no idea what
you're talking about i'm like you know
what i gotta be honest you're right but
you know what i do know what i'm talking
about when i'm talking about freedom i'm
a freedom expert policy wise this will
not work centralization command
economies all this stupid bs mandated
medical procedures it doesn't work let's
talk about what's going on in australia
again because i love to they have
created camps they have just uh we did
the story the other day they arrested
three teenagers who tested negative
because they tried escaping from the
camp
how is this making anything better i
don't think it is it's making it worse
and i think this is what they want they
want to
use a crisis to gain more control
and it's working because i'll throw it
back to when you ask the question about
all these areas that have high
vaccination rates but also high case
rate
population density correlates with
politics
and likelihood of infection so new york
for instance overwhelmingly blue
overwhelm a higher vaccination rate also
a whole bunch of people jam-packed
together in one of the densest
populations in the world and so the
likelihood they're going to spread stuff
and have you know more contact with
different strains of whatever virus yeah
it's really really high so there's a
correlation there that's why i'm like
we got to be careful about playing
correlation games because yeah but but
even that tim even that tim is contested
when you look at vermont and florida
florida has a huge elderly population
huge major metropolitan areas and and
and it's a far more significant state
that was more at risk than new york but
if you look at the case numbers per
capita florida right now has the lowest
case numbers and they have no mass
mandates no uh
vaccine mandates no restrictions no
lockdowns compared to new york and they
also have completely different weather
and they are they also and different
treatments and they also have different
treatments and they also probably have
heard immunity yes so i certainly think
the policy is the issue this this is the
the struggle i have with trying to argue
math and science i'm like we don't need
to
florida's policy clearly works you give
people freedom and sure enough whoa look
at that they provided monoclonal
antibodies to people free of charge you
show up to a clinic boom you're all
better i got it it worked for me it's an
emergency use authorization treatment
then you look at a lot of these other
states some of them don't offer this
and they lock you down and we saw this
very early on when it came to the spread
of this what do you need you need
vitamin d you need vitamin c you need
zinc you need iron you and all this
stuff people staying in their homes are
more likely to circulate air this is one
of the studies that came out um a lot
like last year like mid 2020 they said
that people who were in the house were
more likely to transmit this because
they were more likely to be in close
contact with people and have cycled
recycled air no i remember that study
like if you remember like early in the
pandemic andrew cuomo you know had one
of his pr press conferences and he was
you know just just talking to the media
he said what really surprised us is it's
not frontline workers getting sick it's
not homeless people he said
it's people are getting sick in their
homes and and well sure enough months
later you know we we had some good hard
data that shows people the majority of
people are are infected in their own
home i want to know how many people sat
in their house by themselves in between
20 january 1st 2020 and now sat in their
house by themselves with a mask on
how many people i'd be terrified to find
out put a one in the things if you
actually did that type one in the
comments oh they're gonna say no one's
gonna hate on you it's it's an anonymous
just no but ian you're right yeah i have
seen people driving in their cars with
masks on and they're by themselves
i did that once and i will say i'm that
guy
and i'm like well i don't want to i'm
driving to the doctor now it's been i
had it for a week and i'm like well i
don't what if i cough on the in the car
or something i'm like sorry i had it i'm
that guy driving in my car with a mask
on i was like
i contracted covet about a month ago and
it was pretty brutal like you were
saying i i went through after i got out
of my system i had this like feeling
like well i got a mask so okay i'm a
little bit more protective like i felt
that but then like 10 hours later the
mask was all wet from my breath and it
was disgusting peeling it off my face
and it the thought of it protecting me
had completely gone out the window at
that point because it was dirty you know
i just realized everyone's spamming one
in the chat yeah they're all lying you
guys didn't wear your masks in your
house don't troll on me i'm just like
you know what i don't believe this smash
the like button yeah if i'm like we're
wearing that mask there you go if you
wore it or not smash that let's let's
let's let's
go one last point i want to make because
there's something i think you said tim
um and i i saw it on on twitter recently
gavin newsom came out and he said it
pains me to say this but this thing is
seasonal i don't know if you guys saw
that but but knew something
he came out and said it and and i'm like
well you know a lot of smart people i
know like i i wasn't quite willing to go
there yet myself but i was looking at
charts and you put them and you can see
in different states and different areas
it looks like this is moving seasonally
um and newsom came out and said it and
and so i think we need to accept the
fact all our policies all everything
we're trying to do to contain the virus
you know nature is nature it's moving
yeah five times that's a good point
a good point about florida um people
right now are indoors for the winter in
a lot of places in florida they're
outside yeah where it's cold and if you
go live so next year
florida if you look at florida in july
august next year you know what their
numbers are going to be high again
because everyone goes back inside for
the air conditioning right that's my
prediction right very i wonder how many
guys that are getting vaccinated are
getting vaccinated for different
variants i don't think any of you guys
can answer this question and i would
love it
i don't think there's a vaccine for
different variants i think it's one
vaccine well the white house official's
stance on this new variant is you need
to get vaccinated you need to get
boosted in order to deal with the
omnicron variant which the first
preliminary cases are affecting
vaccinated people dr fauci just came out
today and said that you're going to have
to get a vaccine once a year uh and
their official stance and the biden
administration's first move against
omnicron is to get children vaccinated
uh as young as five thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you